foreign
I had known about this this story
for decades
the disaster of 1871 was one of the the
things that basically ended Yankee
whaling in the in the early 20th century
because it was such a devastating loss
what was still there
if anything was still there
it was a question that needed to be
answered
I was the mission coordinator
once we got there it was deeply personal
we were going out we were going to
essentially develop a map of the seabed
between point Franklin and Wainwright
I remember sitting on the after deck of
the The Vessel we were on and thinking
to myself you know this is the same
place where the Whalers tucked in they
were here
and now we're here and and that was a
very powerful experience for me one of
the first things we did was to scan
using Sonar
with sonar you're basically bouncing
sound waves off the seabed and building
a picture from the returning signal
what you're looking for are straight
lines which are rare in nature
what's it look like on the screen
suddenly see these straight lines and
then more horizontal figures blocks and
it's like that
that looks interesting that could be a
piece of a shipwreck
the sonar picked up six features that
appeared to be man-made
but the sonar can be a bit misleading is
it a provocatively shaped group of rocks
or is that the outline of a hull that's
when you need to put eyes on them
diving was not an option
you're literally in water that's just
above freezing you get into that water
and it hurts
to avoid diving we created a drop camera
system that could be lowered to the
seabed
we started to drag the drop camera
around try to get better view of what
was there
see that
suddenly this structure appeared it was
a mess of heavy wood
you could see sections of the hull that
were there indicating some of that
structure had survived you had the
broken ends of the ribs of the frames
that have been nod by the ice
but it's covered in Marine growth
you had some Stone ballast as well that
helped stabilize that ship when it was
afloat you go okay
we've got a shipwreck
this is a copper sheathing were visible
on sections of planking next to the 70
foot long Hull
it was clear evidence that what we were
looking at was a vessel that at least
been built in the 19th century
we now know a shipwreck could survive
underwater from the north Alaskan Coast
[Music]
thank you